oh being nice made me feel terrible I
nominated you for this big award it's
called The International Coalition of
women in government and you won
there's like five winners and you get a
big trophy or something oh my God this
is real I just assumed you were lying
thank you so how long do you think
you'll stay in Pawnee for I don't know
we like it here
I made Andy promise that someday we'll
move to Transylvania but that probably
won't happen until we're like 100.
well for what it's worth I'm really
happy that you and Andy are married why
why because
I love him and I love you why wouldn't I
be happy
oh
what's that
oh
I I couldn't I couldn't quite hear you
please don't make me say it please
my going away present to you will be
that I do not make you audibly say that
you love me
thank you
okay Leslie's coming back get off you
win did I miss a nice moment no yes you
did oh good
okay turn around what why because I'm
about to say something serious and I
can't do it if I have to look you in the
eye please okay
now take your shoes off and wear them
like mittens April okay sorry
when I started working for you I was
aimless
and just thought everything was stupid
and lame and
you turned me into someone with goals
and ambition which is really the only
reason why I'm even thinking about what
I really want
and then just
want to say thank you
and I love you very much
which is why I've decided not to turn
you into a sea urchin which I could do
because I am an actual witch with powers
and I'm evil and I hate everything I
know you do I'm nervous
look at me you were going to pass this
test and you're going to become a cop
and if you don't I'll just divorce you
and marry someone else and then cheat on
them with you oh it's so sweet also I
got you a lucky charm
I found a dead rabbit on the side of the
road and I cut his feet off and made it
into a lucky charm baby you are so
creepy
thank you I love it
what
oh
[ __ ] hey
Tom and Anne are on a date I know I
don't even know how do you know
because
I set them up
I was watching Anne with Tom at the
dance
and she seemed to be having a good time
so I went over and talked to her what
are you looking for in a date anyway I
don't know what does anyone want just a
nice funny guy who
likes me and treats me well Tom's funny
and he treat you well ha ha I'm serious
you want a good date why not ask out the
only guy that's made you smile tonight
he's ridiculous all that dumb Swagger
it's an act
he's sweet you should just ask him out
for a drink a thousand percent sure I'd
say yes I bet you guys would have a good
time
man I need to like wrap my head around
this why it makes sense to me this is a
small loser
Illusions like at least semi-cool you
know what I'm hearing
you tried to make Anne happy for
Valentine's Day
you're a very nice person very nice yes
you are very nice
I think it's got to be someone okay Ben
you know that I despise you and that I
want you and all people on Earth to be
miserable right sure or you should be
mayor you're the best person for the job
and you deserve it plus this would erase
ice town it's been torturing you since
you were 18 years old and if you became
mayor of Pawnee you could put it behind
you once and for all
being nice made me feel terrible
he said he wanted me to head up the
company I have no idea how to run a
non-profit hey
you shine shoes for over two years and
never made a profit
come on you can hack this
I believe in you
but to replace you I am going to have to
build a scarecrow replica of you and
take it to the movies
it seems like the only logical solution
sorry I can't go through with this I was
gonna pull a prank
no yeah I've hired these guys in ski
masks to kidnap us and I was gonna
pretend to be a hero they were going to
shoot me and drive the van into the
river and that's when the divers would
go in pull you guys out of the water and
I would be standing on the shore like
hey get pranked much
though I haven't got these squibs from
this special effects guy and I was gonna
say this code word and that's when I
would push this button no
oh my God you got blood all over me
thank you
I mean it
Ben that was amazing right right best
prank ever
I made a marshmallow Ron Swanson
oh my gosh his arms are crossed because
he's mad at all the other marshmallow
workers for annoying him you like it
that's fine when I was trying to um I
miss Andy and you probably miss your
lover Chris Leslie I had an idea it's
Friday pawnee's only a 10 hour drive
road trip oh I don't know I was gonna
try and get a jump on some work this
weekend dude 30 years from now when
you're on your deathbed what are you
gonna remember organizing files or
taking a spontaneous road trip to
surprise Leslie yeah you know what all
right I'm in you know we might be able
to sneak out early you get snacks I'll
bring music we'll jam out to some sweet
tunics you know what this is awesome
actually no I don't want to go anymore
oh okay just kidding see you in 10
minutes okay just kidding we're not
going
road trip so we're going yes
hey hey are you leaving well I just have
to get a jump start on my next phase
let's see it is 48-hour Roadkill
scrape-a-thon
okay well before you go I have something
for you
I feel like you're getting sad about how
stupid and lame people are and that is
my job not yours so I'm gonna read this
letter to you out loud but if you hug me
afterwards I swear to God I'll scream
and pull my hair out and maybe punch you
in the face okay
okay please sit
dear award committee members
Leslie I didn't even start okay I'm
sorry
go ahead dear award committee members
where I live there are a lot of
apathetic people
who don't care at all about what they do
or how they do it they let the world
wash over them and barely notice anyone
else is even there Leslie Knope is not
one of these people
she cares about everything and everyone
in our town I don't know how she does it
people come to her with the pettiest
stupidest problems and she cares like
really actually cares what happens to
them and if you're lucky enough to be
her friend your life gets better every
day
she spends every waking moment thinking
of new ways to make her friends happy
there is something wonderful about
seeing someone who has found her true
purpose on Earth
for some people I guess that's being an
astronaut or a hot dog eating champion
for Leslie her true purpose on Earth her
true meaning is making people's lives
better
that's what I love about her and that's
why she deserves this award
sincerely Satan
you're getting hugged right now no I
told you not to yeah